we film this throughout the summer I
mean all all the production all the
planning all the inspiration the
dreaming up up all the set the wardrobe
and all the how the wardrobe ties in to
all the rooms and that was dreamed up
way before that but when we got into
summer it was time to shoot it and it
was like 90 degrees in LA and in this
like airplane hangar that we shot it in
didn't have air conditioning so I was
wearing Christmas clothing on my feet
like 16 hours a day like trying to make
Christmas happen and I think we did this
is known as Christmas special if you
hear from her I'm just in it Nana was my
booking agent whenever I was 12 11 12
she would always walk around with it my
taste somewhere on her person just ready
to just fling it out to anybody who
wants to listen but she's so adorable
and she's been such a big sport my whole
life and she does love to spotlight a
little bit she loves sparkle that's
where I got my love of sparkle from her
you know it's just the Texas grandma so
naturally and she loves Christmas so we
had to have her I just thought it was
really fun for me
even though you know it was a female
centric night which I'm kind of like
century music was built on females
female narratives I don't think it
should be limited just one night
personally though I am appreciative of
the effort I I was proud to stand up
there with a male icon that I've looked
up to my entire life as a woman as a
songwriter standing next to a male
counterpart that we know I know have a
friendship with that we respect each
other
I mean it's just another way to
represent people's autonomy and then
Female Vocalist like I didn't expect
that idea I don't consider myself like
you know a crazy singer I'm not like
doing this
like I can't really do that but I use my
voice in different ways and it usually
fits
and into my lyrical voice so